did you know that Mars has polar icecaps
just like we do here on earth with the
right technology they might be our water
source should we ever move to the red
planet but in their current state these
caps could be a source for extreme
interplanetary sport want to ski on snow
unlike anything else in the universe
want to test your skills on the biggest
mountain in the solar system bring your
80 snow suit if you must just be sure to
pack a good helmet this is what if and
here's what would happen if you could
ski on Mars even though Mars is much
smaller and much colder than our planet
its abundance of water ice makes it a
compelling option for life on another
planet and with the concept of a future
Mars colony gaining popularity homes on
the red planet might soon be on the
market if we do end up living on Mars
someday what would we do for fun
technology will have advanced so
there'll be a lot on offer but what
about the classics like enjoying the
great outdoors could we go skiing on
Mars lucky for you Mars is home to the
highest mountain in our solar system
Olympus Mons is a shield volcano that's
21,000 meters tall that's more than four
times higher than the highest ski slopes
on earth but if you call yourself a
Black Diamond devil then this isn't the
hill for you it turns out Olympus Mons
is more boring than the bunny hill it
has an average slope of just 5 degrees
and considering that Martian gravity is
just one third of what we experience
here on earth it might take you a while
to get started
on the flipside because of that weak
gravity you can jump three times as high
so this could be this
let's not get ahead of ourselves we
haven't even started moving yet with an
average temperature of minus 60 degrees
it's definitely cold enough to snow on
Mars but considering it's dry
low-pressure atmosphere snow barely
reaches the surface and never stays for
very long that said Mars does have two
poles that consist of water ice and
carbon dioxide which in solid form is
dry ice and at Mars is South Pole
there's a dry ice deposit that's 1,000
meters deep but before you give it a go
it's important to note that the friction
from your skis will heat up the dry ice
and turn it into a gas causing you to
lose control if you really wanted to you
could try your luck on the water ice but
its density brings it closer to the ice
skating conditions you'd find on earth
so why use a flat ski when you could go
further with a sharp blade then again
there's more than one way to ski so if
you're that determined to make this work
then just slap on some hard wax and take
things cross-country or is that cross
planet whichever style you choose it's a
double-edged sword shorter and thinner
skis are your best bet for reaching fun
speeds but they're also going to have to
support your clunky space boots and if
you don't get the balance right well you
had a good run so while you could go
skiing on Mars the risks are probably
not worth the reward
maybe stick to something safer like
walking whatever you do wear a helmet
and keep watching what if
[Music]